Чому Путін брязкає зброєю на кордонах України?
На думку опитаних DW експертів, він переслідує одразу декілька цілей.
Перш за все, внутрішньополітичних. Це переключення уваги Заходу
та жителів Росії з теми Навального, а також підготовка до цьогорічних виборів у Держдуму.
Президенту Путіну зараз важливо ще сильніше зміцнити військові бази на півострові Крим.
Водночас поки я б не стала переоцінювати ситуацію:
потрібно пам'ятати про те, що в Росії цього року відбудуться вибори до Держдуми.
Тож, з боку Володимира Путіна це швидше за все лише гра м'язами.
Він прекрасно усвідомлює, що економічна ситуація в Росії зараз погана.
Тому він хоче продемонструвати свою владу і силу,
а також відволікти від внутрішніх проблем у державі.
Інформація про те, що в різних точках на кордоні з Україною розташовані
приблизно чотири тисячі російських військових, з'явилася в газеті The New York Times
наприкінці березня. З посиланням на джерела видання повідомило,
що Європейське командування збройних сил США змінило рівень оцінки
ситуації в регіоні з "можливої ​​кризи" на найвищий статус "потенційно неминучої кризи".
Це реакція на те, що Росія не вивела свої війська після закінчення навчань 23 березня.
Кремль у відповідь на стурбованість спостерігачів заявляє,
що переміщення збройних сил в межах власної території - це внутрішня справа країни.
На думку експертів, дії Росії мають демонстративний характер,
проте не виключено, що нагнітання ситуації може призвести і до реальних бойових дій.
Росії конче потрібен новий засіб тиску на Захід.
Ще недавно таким засобом торгу, тиску була загроза,
що якщо ви будете оголошувати санкції, ми будемо ще більше труїти
російську опозицію, знищувати права людини. Ця логіка діяла до арешту Навального.
Нині ж Захід розуміє, що пріоритет Путіна - це придушення опозиції,
і пом'якшити цю дію будь-якими поступками він не може.
Як наслідок ця схема перестала працювати і виникла необхідність
отримати якийсь новий засіб тиску на Захід.
І я підозрюю, що цим засобом буде загроза розв'язати війну в Україні.
Все-таки ЄС вклав багато сил і коштів, щоб такої війни не допустити -
ставки високі. І саме час полякати.
З іншого боку, деякі експерти сумніваються,
що в разі справжніх бойових дій Київ може розраховувати
на реальну військову допомогу з боку Заходу.
Будемо чесними: я не очікую, що Сполучені Штати
чи європейські країни надішлють солдатів до України.
Але що європейці та американці можуть зробити - це надати Україні зброю.
Ще однією можливістю було б надіслати до України військових радників -
якщо українська влада попросить про це.
Якщо українці вірять, що хтось прийде і безпосередньо підтримає їх
шляхом воєнного втручання - вони помиляються.
Вони повинні налагоджувати відносини з Росією і сепаратистами
зі Східної України політичним шляхом, щоб гарантувати мир.
Це повинно бути головною метою президента Зеленського та уряду.
Водночас ЄС може їм надати лише політичну підтримку, кажучи:
"Ми з вами". І це все. Ми повинні бути реалістами.
ЄС не введе свої війська у східну частину України, щоб домогтися миру.
Брюссель нині традиційно висловлює занепокоєння
зростанням кількості російських військових біля кордонів України.
При цьому головний дипломат ЄС Жозеп Боррель також зазначив,
що Євросоюз підтримує суверенітет і територіальну цілісність України.
Раніше з подібною заявою виступили глави МЗС Німеччини та Франції.
Крім того, Берлін і Париж вказали на "зростаючу кількість порушень
перемир'я" після стабілізації ситуації на Донбасі торік.
Ми дуже уважно спостерігаємо за ситуацією,
особливо за пересуваннями російських військ, і закликаємо
сторони до стриманості та негайної деескалації.
Про підтримку "суверенітету і територіальної цілісності України
в умовах триваючої агресії Росії на Донбасі та в Криму"
раніше заявили і США. Деякі експерти не виключають,
що брязкання зброєю з боку Росії
справді може призвести до бойових дій.
Росія, звісно, захоче спровокувати Україну,
тобто виставити все в такому світлі, начебто агресія походила від Києва.
Цього необхідно за можливості уникнути.
Я не виключаю, що справа дійсно може дійти до великомасштабних військових дій.
Але ми вже були багато разів свідками такої ситуації.
Необхідно думати у довгостроковій перспективі:
Захід повинен постійно робити так,
щоб Росії дедалі дорожче обходилися такі дії.
Це означає, що потрібно бути напоготові:
необхідно уважно стежити за ділянками вздовж кордонів,
потрібно також негайно обміркувати стратегію захисту для Європейського Союзу.
Водночас важливо послати Україні сигнал:
що б не сталося, Києву буде надана підтримка!
Український політолог Володимир Фесенко вважає, що брязкання зброєю
і демонстрація військової загрози - це спроба Росії змусити Україну
піти на поступки у переговорах із сепаратистами на Донбасі.
З іншого боку, це можна сприймати і як спробу почати новий раунд
торгів із Заходом - як з адміністрацією президента США,
так і з європейськими партнерами.
На думку політолога, йдеться про широкий спектр тем:
від санкцій проти Росії до "Північного потоку-2".
Але загроза прямого військового конфлікту
при цьому все-одно зберігається.
Що небезпечно - зараз періодично відбувається
концентрація військ у Криму. І Крим фактично став величезною військовою базою,
причому базою, де зосереджено сучасне стратегічне і тактичне озброєння -
не тільки Чорноморський флот, а й великі військові угруповання,
зосереджена авіація наступальна.
І ще одна нова тенденція - вона проявилася в останні два-три роки -
це проведення масштабних військових навчань на території Білорусі,
що загрожує вже не тільки Україні - ризик нападу з Півночі,
але й загрожує країнам Балтії, Польщі
та всьому східному флангу Європейського Союзу.
За даними ОБСЄ, кількість порушень перемир'я
в одній лише Луганській області зросла у 14 разів.
Росія готується до можливої ​​ескалації конфлікту
на Донбасі та навколо Донбасу. Розпочнеться чи ні - це дещо інша історія.
Військові готові, а чи буде команда політиків?
Приблизно пів року - з липня-серпня до нового року -
було припинення вогню на Донбасі. Причому реальне.
Майже не стріляли. А з січня розпочалася ескалація.
Причому ескалація як на полі бою,
так і ескалація пропаганди з російського боку,
що начебто українці готуються напасти,
що українці готують агресію, що вбивають там
жінок та дітей і що треба щось робити.
На думку експертів, до травня
з урахуванням погодних умов військових дій не очікують.
Однак оглядачі не сумніваються, що Кремль
продовжить політику шантажу і тиску щодо України
і відзначають, що, по суті, це гра з вогнем.
Адже від брязкання зброєю до війни може бути один крок.